>> Sean: MORE UNFOUNDED
HYSTERICAL OUTRAGE, A LOT
RECENTLY SIGNED BY
RON DeSANTIS PROHIBITS SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES FROM GIVING CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTIONS ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
FOR KIDS IN KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
THIRD GRADE.
THAT'S ALL.
THE MEDIA MOB HAS BEEN
PURPOSEFULLY LYING ABOUT WHAT'S
IN THIS BILL AND WHAT IS NOT
AND, OF COURSE, IT'S NOW NOT
STOPPING THE FAR LEFT RAGE MOB
SAYING IT BANS THE USE OF THE
WORD "GAY."
COMPANIES LIKE DISNEY AND
CONTINUING TO AMPLIFY THESE LIES
USING THE OPPORTUNITY TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON THEIR OWN FAR LEFT
CORPORATE AGENDA AS THE COMPANY
NOW SAYS THEY ARE DITCHING THE
WORD "BOYS AND GIRLS" LABELS
FROM ALL PARK GREETINGS BUT YOU
CAN SAY, GREETINGS BOYS AND
GIRLS, CLAIMING IT'S ABOUT
INCLUSION.
NEW LEAD TO VIDEOS FROM INSIDE
GINA PURPORT TO SHOW THIS IN
ACTION.
LISTEN TO ONE IS ACTIVE SAYING
THAT SHE WANTS ALL DISNEY
CHARACTERS TO BE LGBTQ OR
MINORITIES BY THE END OF THE
YEAR.
HERE WITH REACTION, WE HAVE OUT
KICK FOUNDER CLAY TRAVIS AND
TAMMY BRUCE.
IT'S KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
THIRD GRADE AND IT GIVES THE
PARENTS THE RIGHTS TO INSTALL
THEIR VALUES AND THEIR KIDS.
IT NEVER SAYS IN THE BILL, DOES
IT?
>> NO, IT DOESN'T.
THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT, SEAN, OF
A HOPE HATE CRIME.
THEY DESCRIBE SOMETHING ON THE
LEFT THAT DOES NOT EXIST AND
THEY USE IT TO AMPLIFY
THEMSELVES, TO GAIN POLITICAL
POWER, TO INCREASE VICTIMHOOD,
AND THE MEDIA AMPLIFIES IT EVEN
MORE.
IT DOES NOT EXIST.
THE DISNEY DYNAMIC IS ANOTHER OF
THAT, WITH DISNEY BANNING THE
WORDS "BOYS & GIRLS CLUB'S
QUALCOMM THEY ARE COMPLAINING
THAT THIS BILL IN THEIR
IMAGINATION BAND SAYING THE WORD
GAY.
THE ONLY PEOPLE BANNING WORDS
THESE DAYS LIKE WOMAN OR BOY AND
GIRL IS THE LEFT.
FOR THE GAY COMMUNITY AND FOR
EVERY PARENT OUT THERE, EVERYONE
MUST KNOW THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE AGENDA.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE SPENT YEARS
THROUGH THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE KNEW IF AMERICANS KNEW
THAT WE WERE NOT AFTER THEIR
CHILDREN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
WE ARE THEIR FRIENDS, NEIGHBORS,
COWORKERS.
THIS IS THE HOMOPHOBIA OF
CONFLATING SOMETHING THAT
INCREASES PARENTAL RIGHTS WITH
HOMOPHOBIA, SUGGESTING THEN THAT
IN ORDER TO BE PRO-YOU WOULDN'T
WANT PARENTS TO HAVE RIGHTS TO
THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS IS OBSCENE.
IT IS A VIAL.
IT MUST NOT STAND.
EVERY PARENT OUT THERE, THIS
DOES NOT MAKE YOU A HOMOPHOBE.
IT MAKES YOU SOMEONE WHO CARES
ABOUT CHILDREN IN THE FUTURE.
IT COULD BE ANY ORIENTATION.
THERE IS NOTHING IN HERE ABOUT
OR.
BUT THEY GAY COMMUNITY, THE
ORGANIZED LEFT, THE ACTIVISTS ON
THE LEFT NEED ANOTHER CAUSE AND
THIS SEEMS TO BE IT.
>> Sean: THIS IS GOING TO
ALIENATE HALF THE COUNTRY AND
PEOPLE ARE JUST GOING TO STOP
PAYING EXORBITANT FEES TO TAKE
THEIR KIDS THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I PREDICT.
I'M A LITTLE OLD-FASHIONED BEAR
THE SCHOOLS ARE FAILING OUR
KIDS.
HOW ABOUT THEY FOCUS ON READING,
WRITING, MATH, SCIENCE, AND
COMPUTERS AND IF THEY WANT TO
LET KIDS OPT IN ON THESE TOPICS,
HOW ABOUT THEY DO THAT AFTER
SCHOOL AND THE PARENTS CAN
ENROLL THEM FOR EXTRACURRICULAR
SEX EDUCATION CLASSES?
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING, SEAN?
THEY AGREE WITH THIS DEAL.
THREE KIDS, THERE'S NO REASON TO
TALK ABOUT SEXUALITY IN THE
SCHOOL WITH KINDERGARTEN, FIRST
GRADER, SECOND GRADERS, OR THIRD
GRADERS.
IT'S NONSENSICAL.
RON DeSANTIS IS RIGHT, THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA, AND SO ARE
THE LEGISLATURES WHO PASSED THIS
BILL.
BY THE WAY, FOR GENERATIONS,
THEY HAVE SAID AT DISNEY, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, BOYS & GIRLS
CLUB.
THEY HAVEN'T DECIDED, SEAN, THAT
IT ISN'T INCLUSIVE ENOUGH.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT A GENTLE MAN
AND CERTAINLY I AM NOT, BUT I
KNOW THAT TAMMY IS CERTAINLY A
LADY.
BOYS AND GIRLS, THAT COVERS
EVERY BODY!
DID YOU SEE THE STORY...
THE STORY THAT JUST CAME OUT.
FOX ASKED DISNEY, ARE YOU GOING
TO STAY COMMITTED TO THE IDEA OF
PRINCE AND PRINCESS IS.
EVERY STORY THAT DISNEY HAS EVER
MADE, DISNEY DECLINED COMMENT,
SEAN, WHETHER THEY WOULD
CONTINUE TO REFER TO MALES AS
PRINCES AND PRINCESSES FROM ALL
THESE YOUNG KIDS STORIES BUT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FOUR MOST
CHILDREN'S COMPANY IN THE WORLD
AND THEY ARE LOSING THEIR MIND.
SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED FOR NOT
STANDING UP AGAINST THIS CEO.
ALL THESE KIDS IN ALL THESE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE NOT
PROFICIENT IN READING, NOT
PROFICIENT IN MATH, NOT
PROFICIENT IN SCIENCE, THEY ARE
NOT PROFICIENT IN COMPUTERS.
WE ARE NOT DOING THE BASES.
BUT WE WILL SPEND ALL OUR TIME
WITH THIS WOKE MATERIAL AND
DISNEY IS GOING ALO